[Music]
over the past year and a half i've been
doing some healing and self-reflective
work
and through this work i've had the
revelation that i identify as non-binary
in what has been a very honest year for
demi along with coming out as non-binary
they also opened up about identifying as
pansexual on the joe rogan experience
podcast
i'm so fluid now and
you mean like sexually fluid yeah yes
girls you like boys
yeah yeah yeah um
anything really so i just what do they
call that like pansexual or something
like that
yeah yeah pansexual i'm a part of the
alphabet mafia
and proud country star tj osborne of
brothers osborne
publicly came out in time magazine
saying i'm very comfortable being gay
i find myself being guarded for not
wanting to talk about something that i
personally don't have a problem with
that feels so strange and while
appearing on ellen
tj shared how he felt after coming out
not only is it a weight off of my
shoulders to kind of tell my truth
but i don't think i i expected a wave of
love from
family and friends and i did not expect
it to feel the way it felt
[Applause]
superstar jojo siwa started her coming
out journey by posting a picture in a
shirt that read
best gay cousin ever after fans rallied
behind her
jojo took to her instagram to remind her
fans there
is plenty of love in the world i think
coming out
has this stigma around it that it's a
really really really scary thing
but it's not anymore there's so many
accepting
and loving people out there that
it's okay although jojo isn't ready to
put a label on her sexuality
at the glad media awards jojo gave a
shout out to her girlfriend
kylie ah i have the
best most amazing wonderful girlfriend
in the entire world who makes me
so so so happy and that is all that
matters
former wwe superstar gabby tuft came out
as transgender
and shared with us when she knew it was
time
when i was ready to tell my story i had
this
gut feeling that can't be described any
other way than
divine to just be transparent and i knew
in my heart and my soul that
99 of the people would be welcoming
they'd be understanding and they would
support it
i just knew that if i was transparent
and truthful 100
there was nothing to hide that i would
be accepted
and we would start changing the world
and that's exactly what happened
and r b star kelani who had been open
about being queer in the past
came out as a lesbian in a viral
tick-tock video and they're like kelani
what's new when i'm like a funny normal
lesbian
well it's true i am gay gay
gay after deleting the tick tock kelani
opened up to the advocate
about their privilege as a queer artist
saying i think that there are quite a
few artists who were truly at the
forefront but weren't able to make the
strides that i was able to make being
100 myself
because the way they present and the
biases and the phobias of the american
public and the world
i've been lucky super lucky